To get a better understanding of quantitative easing
in the American context, especially the context
that Ben Bernanke is talking about,
I want to read this quote from a speech that
Ben Bernanke gave at the London School of Economics
on January 13th, 2009. So this is shortly
after a lot of the craziness of the financial crisis
was happening but it was still going on.
And he's saying, "Our approach, which could be described as
'credit easing' -- resembles quantitative easing in one respect."
He's saying it's not quite quantitative easing,
although it really is.
"It involves an expansion of the central bank's balance sheet."
So just to understand what he's talking about,
the central bank, it has liabilities and assets,
like any corporation, and they have to,
the liabilities, plus the equity has to match up to the assets.
Just for simplicity, let's just have the assets and the liabilies
lining up together. So let's say that this is the central bank's
balance sheet right over here.
This is their current assets, and let's say
that is is their liabilities over here,
so liabilities, and then this is their equity,
although the federal reserve's equity is a little bit strange,
it's not like traditional equity, that they get all the
excess profits and all of that, all the excess
profits actually go to the US government.
But when the fed prints money, what they literally do
is that they create offsetting liabilities and assets
So when they print money they'll, so literally
let's say that they're printing some money right over here,
so that's money that they're printing,
so this is literally, it would be federal reserve notes
being created, so these are notes, which are essentially dollar bills.
So these are dollar bills right here being printed,
either physically or electronically.
And then they have an offsetting liability
which is just notes outstanding, which is literally saying
that hey, these are notes that we've created.
Notes outstanding is the other side of the balance sheet.
So, just to parse the statement, when he says, "credit easing
resembles quantitative easing in one respect
it involves an expansion of the central bank's balance sheet."
So this is the expansion of the central bank's balance sheet.
Which is essentially the same thing as printing money.
And the federal bank will get these notes into
circulation by going out into the market
and buying assets.
Traditionally, when the fed is more focused on
short-term interest rates,
on overnight borrowing rates between banks,
it will use these to buy shorter-term debt
that increases the amount of currency out there
the amount of dollars out there, and so it will
lower the interest rate for people buying
and selling dollars, or I should say
borrowing and lending dollars, not buying and selling.
Borrowing and lending dollars, the overnight rate
for banks will go down because there's more dollars out there,
the cost of borrowing them will go down.
That's normally what the fed is concerned about.
And they're saying, look, quantitative easing is just
this idea of expanding that balance sheet.
Let's keep reading:
"However, in a pure quantitative easing regime,
the focus of quality is the quantity of bank reserves,
which are liabilities of the central bank;
the composition of loans and securities on the asset side
of the central bank's balance sheet is incidential."
So he's saying in traditional quantitative easing,
the central bank says look, I just care about printing money
I just care about printing money,
So their liabilities increase accordingly.
So this is notes outstanding again,
And the height here is proportional to how much money
they print, so maybe this is another trillion
dollars they're printing.
But what the federal reserve is saying, in traditional
quantitative easing, all the central bank cares about
is printing this money and getting it out there
into circulation, and they don't really care
what they're using this money for.
So whenever they get this money into circulation
they do go out there and they do buy assets
usually treasury assets,
and then they say even, "Indeed, although the
bank of Japan's policy," -- so he's comparing
relative to what Japan did when they kind of faced deflationary crisis.
"Indeed, although the bank of Japan's policy approach
during the quantitative easing period was quite
multifaceted, the overall stance of its policy
was gauged primarily in terms of its target for bank reserves."
So you're saying look, the Japanese were trying to fight
a deflationary bank crisis, they kept printing money
so they kept increasing the liability side of their
balance sheet, they kept printing money
and they did use this money for a bunch of stuff,
they did use that money to go buy a bunch
of assets, but their focus of their intervention
was just, how much did they print?
They didn't really care, they didn't really
engineer where that money went to.
They really weren't trying to change what happens
in the markets that they were participating in.
Let's keep reading what the fed is saying.
"In contrast, the Federal Reserve's credit easing
approach focuses on the mix of loans and securities
that it holds and on how this composition of assets
affects credit conditions for households and businesses."
So what he's saying is that, we are mechanically
doing the same thing that Japan did,
we're increasing our balance sheet, which is analogous to printing money
And we are also buying a bunch of stuff,
just like Japan did,
Japan had a multifaceted approach,
that's how they put the money into circulation,
but what Bernanke is saying
is that our approach isn't just focused on the amount
of cash that we are printing, our focus is
where are we putting that cash toward,
how can we use this cash that we printed
to kind of, provide liquidity, to ease up things
in certain parts of the economy. To understand
what he's talking about, let me draw
a yield curve right over here.
Let me draw this yield curve right over here,
so this is maturity on the horizontal axis,
and this is yield,
and I'm gonna draw the yield curve for treasuries.
So let's say the short-term overnight borrowing for,
let's say, let's do the yield curve for treasuries,
maybe it looks something like this.
So short-term interest rates are already
pretty darn close to zero, and maybe you know
this is some, I don't know what percentage,
maybe this is like 4% or something.
It's not accurate, but just gives you an idea.
So this is the treasury yield curve.
Now you could also have a yield curve for other types of
debt. Maybe you have AAA corporate debt,
a very safe corporate debt, a perceived safe corporate debt,
but it's not quite as safe as US treasuries,
so maybe it's yield curve might look something like this
and this difference, for any maturities,
maybe this is a 10 year,
this is 10 year debt right here.
This difference between this AAA corporate debt
and the treasury, that is the yield spread.
And maybe the fed is able to, through intervention,
first they're able to print money,
normally they buy shorter-term debt,
maybe they start buying longer-term treasury debt,
and maybe that helps get the yield curve,
for longer-term treasuries down a little bit.
Helps bring it down.
But maybe the AAA corporate debts
don't react, maybe the spread doesn't stay constant
maybe the spread widens. Maybe the same thing
for other types of debt. This is highly rated
mortgage backed securities, maybe they have a
slightly higher interest rate.
And once again, even though the treasury interest rates
are coming down, while they're intervening
because of all the craziness that is happening in the economy,
the spread between treasuries, and AAA mortgage
backed securities, or the spread between treasuries
and AAA corporate debt
that widens, or another way to think about it
is the treasury interest rates are coming down
while these things aren't following it,
so what Ben Bernanke is saying, look we are doing
quantitative easing, we are printing money
and we are using that money to go buy things in the economy
and we're increasing the amount
of cash that there is in the economy,
but our point isn't to increase the amount
of reserves, or increase the amount of cash,
because it's really not changing the behavior
of banks. What we are going to do is
go buy things like highly rated mortgage backed securities,
or things like commercial paper, AAA corporate debt,
so that those things, the interest on those things
goes down. Obviously if someone is willing to pay more
for a certain amount of debt,
and I've gone over this in another video,
maybe it's not so obvious,
then the interest rates on it will go down.
And so what they're doing is, what Bernanke is saying,
is he cares more about what winds up on the
asset side of the Fed's balance sheet,
because it takes these dollars that it printed,
and goes and buys other stuff,
and it wants to put some mortgage backed securities
over here, it wants to put some AAA corporate debt
over here. And maybe it also does some longer term
treasury securities, or whatever else.